as he walked along he saw a man blind
from birth his disciples asked him rabbi
who sinned this man or his parents that
he was born blind jesus answered neither
this man nor his parents sinned he was
born blind so that God's works might be
revealed in him we must work the works
of him who sent me while it is day night
is coming when no one can work as long
as I am in the world I am the light of
the world when he had said this he spat
on the ground and made mud with the
saliva and spread the mud on the man's
eyes sang to him go wash in the pool of
Siloam which means sent then he went and
washed and came back a belay burrs and
those who had seen him before as a
beggar began to ask is this not the man
who used to sit in bedding some were
saying it is he others were saying no
but as it is someone like him
he kept saying I am the man but they
kept asking him then how were your eyes
opened he asked he answered them the man
called Jesus made mud spread it on my
eyes and said to me go to Siloam and
wash then I went and washed and received
my sight
they said to him where is he he said I
do not know they brought the Pharisees
the man who had formerly been blind now
it was a Sabbath day when Jesus made the
mud and opened his eyes
when the Pharisees also began to ask him
how he had received his sight he said to
them he put mud on my eyes then I washed
and now I see some of the Pharisees said
this man is not from God for he does not
observe the Sabbath but others said how
can a man who is a sinner perform such
signs and they were divided so they said
again to the blind man what do you say
about him it was your eyes he opened he
said he is a prophet
the Jews did not believe that he had
been blind and had received his sight
until they called the parents of the man
who had who had received his sight and
asked them is this your son who you say
was born blind how then does he now see
his parents answered we know that this
is our son and that he was born blind
but we do not know how it is that now he
sees nor do we know who opened his eyes
ask him he is of age he will speak for
himself
his parents said this because they were
afraid of the Jews for the Jews had
already agreed that anyone who confessed
Jesus to be the Messiah would be put out
of the synagogue
therefore his parents said he is of age
ask him so for the second time they
called the man who had been blind and
they said to him give glory to God we
know that this man is a sinner
he answered I do not know whether he is
a sinner one thing I do know is that
though I was blind I now see they said
to him what did he do to you how did he
open your eyes he answered them I have
told you already and you would not
listen why do you want to hear it again
do you want to become his disciples they
reviled him saying you are his disciple
but we are the disciples of Moses we
know that God has spoken to Moses but as
for this man we do not know where he
comes from the man answered here is an
astonishing thing you do not know where
he comes from and yet he opened my eyes
we know that God does not listen to
sinner's but he does listen to one who
worships and obeys his will never since
the world began has it been heard that
anyone opened the eyes of a person born
blind if this man were not from God he
could do nothing they answered him you
were born entirely in sins and you are
trying to teach us and they drove him
out
Jesus heard that they had driven him out
and when he found him he said do you
believe in the Son of Man he answered
and who is he sir tell me so that I may
believe in him jesus said to him you
have seen him and the one speaking with
you is he he said lord I believe and he
worshiped him jesus said I came into
this world for judgment so that those
who do that see may see and those who do
see may become blind some of the
Pharisees near him heard this and said
to him surely we are not blind are we
jesus said to them if you were blind you
would not have sin but now that you say
we see your sin remains
okay John 9 and the story of the man
born blind another one of these signs a
miracle that Jesus does that has all
sorts of significant special
significance for the the author of this
gospel reminds me a little bit of some
other stories in the Gospels especially
the business about Jesus anointing the
eyes of the blind and there's a similar
story in mark the blind Bartimaeus that
may have served as the inspiration for
this one and that's a great story isn't
it with that the guy comes to sight just
graduating right and he sees oh I think
there were trees out there and cows or
something yeah exactly
and then eventually he finally gets his
full sight back and I sometimes wonder
if if something like that that the
gradual process of coming to physical
sight might have been the inspiration
for John's story which is a gradual
process of coming to some sort of
spiritual sight and we have the same
sort of sort of crescendo absolutely
where there's something a deeper level
of insight but there's also the
opposition yeah both those things yeah I
think those are two main themes and let
me say a couple of my thoughts on that
and a quick word on the wait time comes
together on the on the growing insight I
think as is so often the case in John
this the physical blindness while
undoubtedly taken literally is also a
kind of metaphor or symbol of spiritual
blindness and the miracle happens as
this man moves from seeing nothing to
seeing more and more and more and it
begins with his acknowledging that that
the change in his own life and by the
great the song Amazing Grace
I once was blind but now I say once was
lost but now I'm found was blind but now
as he straight from John 9 the idea that
the way in which one comes by faith is
first acknowledging the difference in
one's own life and then secondly the
beginning to acknowledge that this has
something to do with the man Jesus it
wasn't just me and then finally and I
think this goes very much back to the
way you've talked all the way along
about the interesting connection between
one's faith and being drawn we act and
we are acted upon throughout this whole
gospel that the final moment of faith of
belief comes only when Jesus actually
seeks him out that he
he can't make himself believe unless the
gift has given him of the presence of
the Living Lord and that's to weed it
into a in a kind of a post resurrection
theme but I think not not unfairly and
ever the way it works in the life of the
church and the opposition is is just the
kind of picture of just belief we get
all the way along they can't believe
that anybody can be changed the first
the first doubt is you can't possibly be
the man who used to sit there I know who
that was
that guy couldn't see squat and here you
are seeing everything and I think from
that day until list that's a major side
of disbelief that is we don't think
anything's ever new and so we have no
hope the second disbelieve is that
anybody can break the rules and still be
from God this whole dispute about a
Sabbath where you have a sense that that
somehow Jesus has now broken the rules
and therefore he's got to be a sinner
and the man's belief I don't care if
he's a sinner I was blind now I see and
then and then the final opposition to
them that they think that the man should
be just asked out that they should throw
him out of their community and at that
point is the place where one reason I
hope we talked about this one a little
bit was that I was persuaded a long time
ago about Lou Martin we've talked about
before who taught it Union Seminary in
New York for a long time and now lives
here in Bethany that that this is one of
those places where two times come
together the time of Jesus and the man
born blind reflects on the time of
John's own community or community very
close to John's own community where
people are trying to decide whether to
believe in Jesus or not and if they do
believe in Jesus the danger they face is
they're going to be cast out of the
synagogue which is what the man's
parents fear in this story and what
happens to him and that and that it's a
kind of promise I think that if one has
faith despite the opposition at the end
of one story there is that kind of
progress where one not only sees Jesus
but is seen by Jesus that one enters
into a kind of full rich community yeah
going back for a moment to the casting
out of the synagogue it's probably worth
reflecting on that just a little bit and
Lew Martin's hypothesis about the
embedding of the history of the
community and the story of Jesus and
there's a lot to that yeah and here the
the essential point is that being cast
out of the synagogue is anachronistic
right absolutely at first century right
holily right it would fit late for a
century certainly Asia Minor or later
Galilee where the synagogue was an
institute yeah there's been a lot of
speculation on what what it was and
whether whether this was a kind of
universal persecution of Christians and
LU and others have toyed with the idea
that you can pin things down to the late
the last decade of the first century
it used to be the case that historians
of Judaism thought that there was a
special event that happened at a Council
of rabbis at a place called Yavne at
which a prayer was introduced into the
synagogue liturgy that would have been
very difficult for a believer in Jesus
to say right now a lot of historians are
a little skeptical of that
reconstruction it's more likely that
there were attempts to rid communities
of messiness of Christians in different
ad hoc so that there was a universal
persecution by Jews of Christians is
unlikely that there were tensions in
Jewish synagogues all over the
Mediterranean over this new Christ faith
during the first century that's highly
likely yeah and some of that is being
reflected in this the story of the man
absolutely cast out of the synagogue so
there's a bit of an anachronism there
which leads to this reading and I think
that's that's probably right the other
thing you're pointing to is a kind of
nice literary feature of this text they
the Greeks used to call it a chiasm an
x-y out like structure so on the one
side you start with physical blindness
that leads really both physical and
spiritual
openness sighs yep and on the other side
you start with what seems to be physical
sight but spiritual blindness and the
kind of arrogance and and
self-assuredness that you have
attributed to the opposition here I
think is in bad politics I think that's
their and they move eventually to a
position of a total blind exactly right
and I condemned as through words of
Scripture so it's a very nice
and you can understand how this is a
kind of reaction today the tension that
some early Christians probably felt from
their cousins brothers sisters or
whatever and they in the synagogue might
be a good time to talk for just a minute
about the way in which Jews are
portrayed in John's Gospel because I
think that's problematic for our readers
today and I very much with you in a
sense that what you have here is a kind
of a record of a family feud and the
Jews and the Pharisees represent the
cousins who stayed in the synagogue and
the good guys are those who split off
and in so as in so many family feud's
know from my time in the pastor that the
worst arguments are between people who
have been very close the divorce or the
fight over the will you can you can be
fairly cordial to your distant enemies
your just miserable to the ones that
were close at hand and I think one of
the dangers has been in Christian
preaching especially that that
contemporary Christians have taken this
as some kind of accurate description of
late first century Judaism and even
worse as if somehow Temple beth-el was
full of hypocritical nitpicking
legalistic Pharisees who don't
understand the richness of grace and
that's not a fair reading either first
century Judaism of Judaism today mm-hmm
no that's right this is certainly not
the worst of the passages no by no means
but I think I touched those that's right
literally yeah we ought to remember that
absolutely the main passage that causes
offence is in the previous chapter in
chapter 8 where Jesus is involved in a
pretty heated controversy with those who
reject and he's laying claim to be the
the true son of Abraham and they're
saying he is no son of Abraham he's
really you know that day the son of a
devil hole or ego in the background and
the background is probably yeah and
Jesus finally winds up calling his
interlocutors they're children of the
devil the murderer from all eternity
pretty awful stuff and has been misused
in Western history in all sorts of ways
I think we've come to recognize how
deleterious that material is in the last
40 or 50 years since the Holocaust and
since we've become more aware of the way
and
Christian preaching used to use this
material yeah this is one of the places
where I think it's very important to
contextualize our reading of the gospel
and understand it as you say is a kind
of family feud in the first century with
some pretty important issues it's a huge
issue
huge issue but ones that can't be
replicated in any simple way in our
other just a couple other things I like
about this story it as with the woman at
the well it's it's very neatly
structured as a kind of drama and in
fact when I use it in churches you can
divvy everybody up and you have the
parents and you have the man born blind
and you have the Pharisees and you have
the disciples and you have Jesus and
it's just it's nicely plotted it's one
of those moments where if we're going to
go with our friend and think that
there's drama in chapter 13 maybe
there's drama here too that this is
somebody who knows how you structure
that and then themes that we've that
we've had already here's the whole light
thing from the prologue so if we go back
to our initial question does the
prologue lead into anything or is it
just kind of a nice set piece at the
beginning here it clearly leads into a
whole theme and you have this judgment
business which is not simply something
we anticipate but has to do with a life
we live now and so to call ourselves
seeing when we're blind is itself
judgment run and on the light theme of
course this is part of the larger
context of the feast of tabernacles word
that starts back there and chapter 7 and
Jesus declares himself in chapter 8 I am
alone world's picking up on the motif of
light at the Feast of Tabernacles we
tend to associate that by the way I
think in this day and age was kind of we
do you know the Chanukah was modeled on
the Feast of Tabernacles when it was
first developed in the second century BC
so that motif is here as a kind of
dominant Jewish liturgical motif and
Jesus is constantly interacting with
that so yeah Jesus the light of the
world comes into the darkness here in
the lumens it in a very dramatic way on
various levels and yeah the story is so
neatly structured another element in
here that picks up on earlier motifs and
looks ahead is this title of the Son of
Man yes yeah which which John plays with
in so many interesting ways and it's
probably useful to remember as we
suggested in one of our
conversations that in a lot of early
Christian discourse the son of man was
associated with Jesus coming as judge
much so right exactly this this
exemplifies the Johanna reinterpretation
of that judgment motif he is the son of
man yeah addressing himself as such
himself to be such being recognized as
such finally by the man born blind and
judgment and here is judgment in that
recognition not in some final
eschatological abandoned also just the
little ironies in the story I like when
he when the man born blind says to the
people who are criticizing him do you
want to be his disciple too man it's
just clearly it's one of those rare
places where John's having a little fun
with his story and and not just disagree
with him of putting them down in a kind
of sarcastic way reminds me of the the
part of the woman or the well where do
we want to be as desired exact same sort
of thing I slit 'el irony as a nice
little Oh God knows how to use irony in
various ways sometimes pretty
heavy-handed and another way in which I
think about this text is in terms of its
application and appropriation the theme
of blindness is something that I think
we can all think about as an element of
our own lives and I this is where the
the Johanna invitation into a dialogue
with the text comes to the floor because
on the one side if you think about it
just in those social terms and who's now
outside if they at the community of
believers you forget that there's a
continuous challenge we talked after we
go about that continuity of challenge
within the community of belief and so I
think John is a gospel as a whole
especially if you think about its
relationship with early a Christian
tradition is in effect a challenge to
those who think they see absolutely
examine their sight exactly and see if
they really understand who this Jesus
hanging on the cross is see I told you
you stayed at the Divinity School long
enough to become a preacher